finalmente alemania no vivirá una semana
santa en medio del parón de la vida
pública por la tercera ola del virus una
polémica decisión que se anunció la
madrugada del martes y que pretendía
sumar dos días festivos en semana santa
tras una acalorada reunión de 11 horas
entre la canciller angela merkel y los
16 jefes de los estados federados pero
el aluvión de críticas que recibió el
gobierno tras el anuncio hizo que angela
merkel convocar a una reunión de
emergencia en la que se revocó la
decisión y ahora estudia además prohibir
provisionalmente algunos viajes al
extranjero muchos alemanes reclamaron al
ejecutivo que ésta no había sido
sometida a debate público y destacaron
los problemas legales debido a su poca
anticipación por lo que merkel pidió
perdón
quiero dejarlo claro este error es
únicamente culpa mía porque al fin y al
cabo yo soy la responsable de todo el
estilete fund fortune las restricciones
de última hora eran
un intento por frenar el repunte de
casos que vive alemania con la tercera
ola del virus y que están aumentando la
presión sobre las unidades de cuidado
intensivo en todo el país no obstante
las medidas no fueron bien recibidas en
un país en el que la pandemia ha
generado una gran recesión económica con
varias manifestaciones en su contra las
críticas al movimiento de merkel
cuestionado hasta en el seno del
gobierno dejaron cifras alarmantes para
los conservadores del cde o los sondeos
que ahora ven un poco más lejos la
victoria en las elecciones federales de
septiembre